this video is sponsored by nordvpn try
nordvpn's risk-free exclusive deal today
thanks to their money-back guarantee
using the link in the description
it was only the second time fred had
hung out with his new friend aubry
outside of school aubry was essentially
fred's first real friend the first
person he really had to put everything
he learned about being a good person and
interacting with others on the table
four with something meaningful at stake
the two had just come inside from biking
around in the driveway rushing from the
door to the living room couch aubry
excitedly said do you want to watch star
trek
do you like that show fred responded
with the neutral tone yeah it's my
favorite it's so good do you
yeah let's watch it fred replied the two
watched the show quietly for the rest of
the afternoon until fred's parents came
and picked him up
fred had in fact seen the show before
but he hated it he wanted to be nice
though which as he understood it meant
putting others needs and desires in
front of your own and not upsetting
people and so he put aubry first avoided
any conflict of interest and agreed to
watch
at least once almost every time they
hung out thereafter aubry put on star
trek
although fred occasionally tried to sway
the activity a different direction he
never explicitly told aubrey how he
actually felt instead by the end of the
school year fred just stopped hanging
out with aubry altogether secretly
having harbored the frustration that
they rarely did or watched anything he
wanted aubry was deeply confused as to
what had happened what was wrong and why
he suddenly lost his friend
when he asked fred fred was coy and
dismissive
[Music]
several years later in high school fred
found himself a part of several small
friend groups with the introduction of
greater freedom driver's licenses and
the pubescent lust for activity fred
also found himself spending far more
time with friends outside of school than
he ever had before
for the first time he had to balance
plans and schedules between different
people and between people and himself
whenever he was asked to do something
whether it was to hang out or do someone
a favor afraid of coming off
disinterested or making any of his
friends upset fred's answer was almost
always a resounding yes
of course since he always agreed he
often already had tentative plans with
other people that overlapped which meant
he often had to figure out how to cancel
most of them
throughout high school fred spent very
little time with himself his hobbies his
interests his schoolwork his peace of
mind and so on
he often felt diminished and used
disproportionately doing things other
people wanted or suggested secretly
developing and harboring a resentment
toward many of his friends and family
members
by graduation he had lost some of his
friends due to his flaky nature and
intentionally but seemingly inexplicably
broke ties with most of the rest
many of them were somewhat confused and
upset by a sudden disappearance
a couple years later during college fred
found himself in his first real serious
long-term relationship with a girl named
tara
the relationship was amazing they
connected with each other in a way fred
had never experienced connection before
tara was beautiful and sweet and funny
and interesting and brought out parts of
him that he didn't even know existed
that made him feel alive he soon fell in
love for the first time
as time passed though
things began to fall apart
tara often did things that upset fred
she would go silent for full days
without responding to his texts she
would go out with friends without ever
letting him know when and where she
might go she would act and react with
very little patience and she would often
ask fred for accommodations while
neglecting his own schedule and needs
by three years in fred no longer felt
the same connection with her that he
once did
who they were when they first met was
not who they were now
fred prided himself on being a nice
easygoing boyfriend in a relationship
void of fights though and so he rarely
addressed things that bothered him
rarely pointed out tara's character
flaws or any of the issues he had in the
relationship and mostly avoided
arguments in general
we like never fight fred said to one of
his friends from college while catching
up at a bar i just don't really like the
way she treats me she doesn't seem to
understand like who i am or where i'm
coming from or
like what i want i don't know i used to
think she did or at least could but i
don't even know if she cares anymore
i mean i'm not necessarily trying to
suggest anything
but have you at least thought about
potentially breaking up with her fred's
friend replied i don't know maybe i just
i want to make things work
i don't want to devastate her you know i
don't know if she would really be able
to be okay with me
i don't know i'll see how things go i
guess
fred stayed with tara for over a year
more he tried to act as if everything
was fine but found himself unavoidably
distancing himself more and more from
her
the breaking point was when he found out
that tara cheated on him
even then he stayed with her for a few
more months she said her reasoning was
she felt neglected and didn't feel like
he loved her anymore he told her he
would try to understand and forgive her
but in actuality he felt like ending
more than just a relationship
not long after fred broke up with her
realizing how much of a fool he had been
it was one of the hardest things he had
ever done
following college fred was out on his
own in the world navigating the early
budding prospects of his career
by 23 he received his first real job
offer related to his career path a
digital marketing coordinator role for a
mid-sized e-commerce company fred
eagerly accepted
in the office fred always put on his
smiley face and happily agreed to
everything he was asked even when it was
outside the scope of his work often
offering to help or pick up any slack
anytime his manager or one of his
co-workers asked not wanting to upset or
disappoint them
he rarely could help with most of what
he took on either in terms of his
ability or his time
in general there was a deep crater of
incongruency between what he presented
about his interest and ambition and how
he actually felt about the work
again and again fred would over promise
and under deliver
secretly he disliked his boss and most
of his co-workers he despised how they
treated and took advantage of him
fred continued in this job for the
following couple years despite it being
well beneath the skill set and upper
management never really offering him a
nearly equivalent opportunity or
compensation
three years in after he couldn't take it
anymore he quit in what seemed like all
of the sudden without much of an
explanation
fred was perhaps one of the nicest
people you could ever meet he always
made sure the happiness and preferences
of those around him were met he never
wanted to upset anyone he was always
willing to go with whatever anyone else
wanted and so when he was 28 years old
and he found himself alone with very few
friends a very short but complicated
list of ex-girlfriends and a strained
awkward relationship with his previous
colleagues and bosses he was extremely
confused
having not had much of a social life let
alone a relationship in a couple years
feeling like he was on the brink of a
life of total isolation fred decided to
start dating again
he had little luck at first but
eventually he met a very unique
spontaneous and extroverted woman unlike
anyone he had ever met before named
amina
while on a third date with her the two
sat at a picnic table in a park while
the sun set behind them they discussed
all sorts of topics including more
personal sentiments of their lives and
pasts which was very uncharacteristic of
fred he shared about his old friends and
jobs and even some of his exes
i don't know it seems like everyone is
just selfish in this world that's
definitely one thing i've learned i feel
like people have just always taken
advantage of me of my niceness i've been
nothing but nice but i just get screwed
over and over
fred said that's true people are
definitely selfish amina replied
a brief pause surrounded the two amina
clearly having more to say i have to say
though up front if we're gonna
potentially you know keep this going
i gotta ask something
okay sure yeah about what
fred replied
are you the kind of guy who is so hung
up on being nice he never really thinks
about other people
what do you mean
fred said confused by the seeming
paradoxical question
like did you ever tell anyone how you
felt did you ever ask them not to do
something did you explain what was wrong
and try to help resolve it
no offense but it kind of seems like you
always just expected people to know how
you felt and to treat you right just
because you were nice
another brief pause filled the space
between them i mean i just don't like
arguing or being mean or confrontational
for no reason especially when people
should kind of already know what's right
fred answered
yeah but how does anyone know of a
problem if the problem is hidden from
them and why would anyone want to solve
it if it benefits them and the other
person doesn't seem to care
i don't think niceness is always kind
because kindness is not quietness
submissiveness or self-surrender
i think it's the willingness to confront
and deal with others and issues honestly
and fairly for everyone's benefit even
when it's difficult or uncomfortable for
you
amina said that's true i agree with that
actually fred replied with a somewhat
dip in his tone
do you i mean a replied laughing
i'm just saying i've dealt with plenty
of selfish people in my life so i
completely resonate with where you're
coming from but some people are so
concerned with not being selfish they
become it they become so centered around
being liked and perceived favorably they
never even consider the consequences of
their so-called niceness
agreeing universally with everyone is
not necessarily a sign that you actually
care about other people but that you
care about what other people think about
you with no regard for how it affects
them how is that not selfish at least
with straightforward people you know
where they stand and what the issues are
maybe their perspectives still aren't
always good but at least they respect
you enough to tell you
the two looked at each other sitting on
opposite sides of the picnic table as if
amina was the antithesis to fred's
entire life laid bare on the table in
front of him
sorry she continued i didn't mean to
come off too forward there i'm just you
know doing my due diligence less time to
waste at this age you know yeah i know i
i get it fred said with a laugh so are
you around this weekend at all we should
do something amina said fred paused then
he said
yeah
maybe we should take things
a little bit slower actually
this video was sponsored by nordvpn
if you're a fan of film tv and content
streaming then you're probably a fan of
having access to more content from some
of your favorite streaming platforms
using your same subscription and you are
probably not a fan of slow internet
speeds and bandwidth throttling
if so you will certainly be a fan of
nordvpn
nordvpn allows you to change your
virtual location with a single click to
over 5400 servers in 60 countries by
doing so nordvpn grants you access to
the various libraries of streaming
platforms like netflix that have
different content offerings based on
where you're located not only that but
when signing up for streaming platforms
and other products and services prices
can also vary based on location meaning
nordvpn can also help you find the
lowest prices available for those who
aren't familiar with the vpn in general
a vpn is a service that hides your ip
address protects your internet
connection and data traffic and
maintains your privacy online nordvpn is
one of the fastest vpns on the market
and uses next generation technology to
encrypt your data traffic twice through
a double vpn keeping you fully secure
concealed and protected no matter where
you are physically and digitally enjoy
all the benefits of fast easy and secure
protection as well as having access to
other locations around the world by
signing up to nordvpn's exclusive deal
today using the link in the description
below you could try it completely
risk-free thanks to their money back
guarantee
again you can go to nordvpn.com
pursuit of wonder or use the link in the
description below
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video